now I'm going to walk you through the
process of getting your workspace set up
on Mac and the process on Linux is
similar
there are also written instructions in
the instructors notes if you're using
Windows there are instructions in the
previous video first I'm going to
download two files that are needed for
the setup I just showed you one to
enable tab completion and one to enable
the special get features in the prompt
so I'll go to the web page with the
first file and you can find a link to
this file in the instructors notes then
I'll right click anywhere on the page
and select save as and I'll save the
file in my downloads directory now I
want to make sure that hide extension is
unchecked so that I can see the exact
name the file is being given and by
default
it's suggesting redirecting dot text but
I want to change this to get completion
dot bash and then I'll save the file now
I want to move the file to my home
directory which I'll do using the
terminal now when I first open the
terminal I start out in my home
directory or I can type CD tilde to get
to the home directory if I need to now
I'll use the command env which stands
for move to move the file I just saved
into my home directory the first
argument is the file I want to move
which is in my downloads directory and
it's named get completion dot dash and I
want to move it into the current
directory while keeping the same name
then I'll go through the same process to
save the second file linked in the
instructors notes as get prompt is H
next I'm going to create a file called
dot bash profile which contains
configuration for the terminal I
recommend using the configuration file
that I used when filming this course to
do that you can download the file called
bash profile course in the downloadable
section next use the terminal to move
this file to your home directory you
should name it dot bash under profile
and don't forget the dot at the
beginning now if you already have a bash
profile then don't run this command and
instead you can copy and paste the
content from this file into your
existing bash profile and if you're
running Linux then you might need to
name this file bash RC instead of bash
profile now I don't see any changes made
to my prompt yet and that's because I'll
need to close
and reopen the terminal before the
changes take effect I'll do that at the
end of the video in case you're curious
about what's in this batch profile or if
you'd like to pick and choose just the
lines you're interested in I'll go
through what each line does now don't
worry if you don't understand how each
line works though even experienced UNIX
programmers frequently copy and paste
this kind of thing from their friends
rather than writing it from scratch this
first line loads one of the files you
downloaded earlier and enables tab
completion these lines define some
colors which will be used in your prompt
this line loads the other file you
downloaded earlier and it's necessary
for the get related stuff like commit
IDs to show up in your prompt this line
is what makes sure that the asterisk
will be shown in your prompt if you make
changes in a git repository and this
line actually defines what the prompt
will be the prompt will show your
username in purple the commits you
currently have checked out or other get
related stuff in green and the directory
you are in followed by a dollar sign in
blue then any text after that will be
displayed in the default color if you're
curious to learn more about how prompts
work in bash check out the link in the
instructors notes but it's not necessary
for the rest of this course next it's
important to make sure you can launch
your favorite text editor from the
terminal so that you'll be able to set
it as your default editor within git
I'll show how to do this for sublime if
you're using another text editor I
recommend that you google to figure out
how to use it from the terminal now I
can launch the blind from the terminal
by running this long command where this
is where sublime is stored on my
computer but I'd like to have a shortcut
to create one I'll use sublime to add a
line to my bash profile files with a dot
at the beginning of the name don't
usually show up in file system explorers
so I'm going to have trouble opening my
batch profile with sublime to fix this
I'll use the trick of moving my bash
profile to a file without a dot at the
beginning of the name then to open the
file in sublime I'll first navigate to
my home directory which I can do by
pressing command shift H and then I'll
select the file bash profile then I'll
add this line to it to make the subtle
command stand for the same command that
you saw me enter earlier
you can copy and paste this line from
the instructors notes if you're using
sublime now I'll save the file and I'll
change the name back to have a dot at
the beginning using the terminal if I
don't do this then the best profile
won't take effect when I open the
terminal again this command won't work
until I've restarted the terminal now
I'll configure get to use sublime as my
editor for things like commit messages
to do that I'll run git config dash dash
global Chordata deter and here I need to
put in double quotes the command to open
my text editor for sublime that's double
dash n dash W where dash n will open
sublime in a new window and dash W will
wait until you close your file before
continuing if you use a different editor
you'll need to modify this part of the
command to use the editor that you like
see the instructors notes for more
details next I'll run things to get
config commands which will come in handy
later in the course please copy and
paste these commands from the
instructors notes and run them finally
I'll close the terminal entry open it
now I can see that my prompt has changed
to become more colorful and if I want to
view my bash profile using sublime
I can run subl dot bash profile remember
to close and reopen your terminal when
you're finished or your changes won't
take effect